this video is sponsored by our online
store at Anime uproar calm where you can
get original anime inspired clothes like
Eskin or praise the Sun meliodas feel
the wrath in our brand new shirt demon
king Mele Otis all hail the king if you
love the seven deadly sins make sure to
check out anime uproar calm and use the
code uproar 25 at checkout to get a
whole 25 percent off your purchase link
in the description
[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and since I recently did the
seven sins ranked from weakest to
strongest I thought I might as well do
my take on the 10 commandments ranked
from weakest to strongest while I'm in
the ranking mood remember to Like and
subscribe for more seven deadly sins
videos and for even more seven deadly
sins content follow us on Instagram
where we've grown a pretty big community
of meme loving anime fans I post seven
deadly sins on there daily so make sure
to check us out on Instagram at anime
uproar linked in the description
keep in mind guys going forward there
will be big manga spoilers you've been
warned
in last place we have fraud Rijn with a
power level of 31,000 he possesses the
commandment of selflessness but he was
never given the commandment directly by
the demon king rather he was a standard
forgo thir who used to be the
commandment of selflessness 3,000 years
ago thus it makes sense that he would be
the weakest roger has the ability to
take over a person's body but it's
definitely not guaranteed that he always
can for instance when he first tried to
take dreyfuses body he was unsuccessful
and had to threaten Hendrickson before
Dreyfuss willingly allowed him to take
his body it is possible that if people
have too high of a spirit level or even
too much power
then the takeover won't work in his
ordinary body he can use the ability
full size to become insanely large
however this doesn't stop Mellie Otis
with a combat class of 60,000 at the
time from easily and brutally defeating
him next we have GLE and the commandment
of truth who normally has a combat class
of 27,000 but can go up to 40,000 in his
critical / mode thus he can become
considerably stronger than fraud Rijn
furthermore his commandment actually
came in handy for him anyone who lies in
his presence will be turned to stone
this commandment temporarily turns
Merlin's body to stone in chapter 121
luckily for us 3,000 years ago the
supreme deity gave her protection
against dark curses and commandments so
she eventually was like oh yeah I have
protection and was able to return to
normal
ghal and was strong enough to give the
sins including bond and I'm not so
strong Mellie Otis trouble but Eskin or
in his daytime form is easily able to
take him out
since go
and only really relies on his physical
strength and his commandment can be
avoided by simply not lying taking him
down is pretty easy you just have to
overpower him and Eskin or was easily
able to do that next we have gray road
the commandment of pacifism who is more
tricky than Galan althoguh land that
full power is slightly stronger than
gray Road whose power level is 39,000
the demons commandment and ability is
more than make up for that tiny
difference gray road can lay eggs in non
magical beings that will eventually
become demons in this way she created a
grey and red demon in the past this is
already a pretty crazy power but it
works perfectly in combination with her
commandment thou shalt not kill those
who commit murder before her have all
their time robbed of them so just kill
one of these demons and you wither away
and die alternatively the demons have no
problem killing the enemy since grey
road is more than willing to sacrifice
some of these demons since she can
create more of them so readily gray road
has the power to cut off someone's five
senses as well which makes defeating
them all the easier however despite all
this gray road is still no match for
Merlin who can easily cure all of gray
roads curses and who is unaffected by
her commandment both her magic infinity
which stops her personal time and her
divine protection that she received from
the supreme deity protects her from the
consequences of grey roads commandment
so that she can freely kill in her
presence usually grey road would be near
impossible to defeat because even if you
manage to get past her demons without
killing them or getting killed by even
killing one of the many tiny grey demons
that make up her body you will activate
her commandment so in theory you would
only get as far as killing one of the
tiny grey demons before the commandment
took you out
however Merlin was the worst possible
opponent gray road could have faced not
only was she unaffected by the
commandments she could also use her
advanced magic to trap gray road inside
a vial so even though grey road was
defeated relatively easily under
different circumstances
she might have fared much better next we
have gloxinia the first fairy king and
commandment of repose according to the
official fanbook locks Enya can reach a
power level of 50,000 which is
significantly higher than grey
and gle and although his commandment
never comes into play we do know that
Garcinia possesses the same ability that
King possess is called disaster this
power allows one to turn small scratches
into gaping wounds or to condense the
moisture within a tree branch enough to
turn it into a potentially deadly bullet
among other things gloxinia is also an
expert wielder of his own spirit spear
but King does eventually surpass him in
power when he gets his own full-grown
wings was pretty funny as I gloxinia
along with troll get hurt by Eskin or
during the nighttime because they let
down their guard and then Mele Otis
takes advantage of the confusion and is
beating them both until the rest of the
commandments arrived gloxinia is strong
but clearly he is not one of the
strongest commandments next up we have
the first giant king troll who was the
Commandant of patients role in locks in
ER often together and their power is
comparable so you could probably make a
case for either one being stronger
however since their power is presented I
was relatively similar in the manga and
the official fanbook gave droll a higher
overall power level of 54,000 I decided
to put him above the first fairy king it
is also notable that while King has
clearly surpassed the first fairy king
in the manga Danns highest power level
was set to be 50,000 so far so drol can
still be viewed as the strongest giant
in history for the time being
furthermore he is probably the greatest
earthbender in the history of the seven
deadly sins and can use heavy metal to
increase his already impressive
defensive and offensive power even more
he has a power increasing dance for
giants named after him and it's the same
technique that Deanne uses to increase
her own power
Baylor's magical eye is actually named
after drawls human named Bale or because
the giant king has the ability to
determine the strength of his opponents
and read their thoughts even though this
power doesn't always work like on Mele
Otis for instance at the end of the day
draw a clock sania were not a match for
a pre-death meli otis and definitely not
a match for chandler they were strong
compared to their clans but they
couldn't compete with many demons so my
next choice is probably controversial
but I'll try to explain why I put her as
high as I did next up I have molasse
Killa the Commandant of faith although
her power level is one of the weakest
34000 I think her unique abilities
should put her this high up unlike with
gloxinia and roll we know what molasse
girl's commandment does in Chapter 145
she explains that everyone's heart
possesses something they have faith in
and believe in whether it's a God the
sword or a lover it's something very
precious to them but people's hearts are
weak they lose their faith over the
smallest matters then we figure out that
anyone who loses faith or harbors
distrust towards that precious something
in her presence will have their eyes
burned not a bad commandment but it's
her other abilities that really
impressed me for instance she can even
bring the dead back to life her
incantation the way of reviving the
hateful dead augments a corpses
lingering attachments and converts their
anger into life force to summon them to
this plain and once they deny their
anger and erase their lingering
attachment then death once again awaits
them this is how she brings back Elaine
who at first attacks Jericho and bond
because of the spell then there's the
power to take out souls from people's
bodies and eat them in this way she
could potentially even beat an immortal
opponent like bond by taking his soul
out of his immortal body and consuming
it truly a fearsome ability that should
not be underestimated
this does backfire when she tries to eat
esken or soul and it burns her from the
inside but to be fair s Kannur
overpowers all of the strongest
commandments at one point including s
serosa and zelgius so we can't really
hold that against molasse co-op
additionally mulaskey laws deadly poison
attack he completely disintegrates a
body in an instant and her cocoon of
Darkness spell gives the seven deadly
sins much more trouble than the
previously mentioned Commandments could
she trap smelly Onis in her cocoon of
Darkness she can take melioidosis
negative energy and use it to reinforce
her zombie soldiers increasing their
attack defense and resistance to magic
in this way she actually uses Mele
Otis's power to help her fight against
the other sins furthermore mulaskey law
says that the cocoon of Darkness is so
strong that not even one of the Ten
Commandments not even zelgius without
using the demon Kings power could escape
from it Mele Otis is only able to do so
by entering assault mode which has a
power level of 142
the lower-ranking Commandments on this
list couldn't push Mellie Otis to that
point which is another reason why I
believe that despite being given a
combat class of only 34,000 she should
be this high on this list although she's
eventually defeated by the sins Merlyn
even points out that if she used her
true magic power then her fight against
the sins could have gone any number of
ways but she was too conceited made
light of them and so decided to fight
them in her snake form which sealed her
fate thus even when she's defeated
Merlyn lets us know that it was because
of her arrogance and not because of a
lack of strength so yeah I spent way
more time in Alaska than I expected to
because I want to justify my decision
but now let's move on to the next
commandment on this list derrière heed
the commandment of purity her power
level is 50 mm so significantly above
mulaskey laws her innate power combo
star can potentially make her blows
unimaginably strong once Pete explains
that it's a super offensive specialized
magic that as long as her combination
attacks hit their mark without any break
adds 200,000 pounds of weight with every
strike two hundred thousand pounds is
over 90 times heavier than Dee Ann's
warhammer Gideon which weighs 2,200
pounds so you can begin to imagine the
force of Derry Aries punch after a
number of combo hits derriere he gets as
many as 54 combo hits on Mellie Otis and
they take his arms out of commission so
he has to fight with his sword in his
mouth the fact that he was still alive
after that shows how strong Mellie Otis
is but imagine if derriere he somehow
kept going if 54 could break Mellie
Otis's arms imagine what 100 or more
could do it's an insanely powerful
ability but there is another reason why
I put derriere so high I am also
thinking about her enduro transformation
in chapter 206 dairy area along with
Mont speed undergo an indirect
transformation by each offering up six
of their seven hearts according to
molasse cola it's a forbidden art the
Summoner exchanges his original form and
sense of reason in order to take on the
ultimate evil form Endura is also called
the creature of destruction only demons
with a combat class of 50,000 or greater
can undertake this transformation
so the previously mentioned Ten
Commandments can't because they either
weren't over a fifty thousand combat
class or if they were they were demons
like luck Sania and role in this forum
derriere II and Mon speed not only
completely overpowered the Archangel
star meal and SAR meal they also
overpower Ludo shell who in Margaret's
body has a combat class of two hundred
one thousand and since during this fight
he was in his own goddess body his power
level had to be even stronger
thus it is safe to assume by the way
they fought against the three Archangels
including Ludo shell that both derriere
II and Mon speed have a combat class of
at least over two hundred thousand in
this form putting them way above the
previously mentioned members the goddess
Elisabeth eventually turns him back to
normal but I still wanted to factor in
the fact that they could use this
insanely strong transformation at one
point it's not a surprise that next I
have Mon speed the commandment of
reticence although I believe that both
moan speed and there you have comparable
strength Mon speed has a slightly
stronger base combat class of fifty
three thousand as mentioned he too
entered the Enduro transformation and
partook in absolutely wrecking the three
Archangels including Ludo shell once
Pete's original power is trick star
which allows him to switch to objects of
roughly equal size or mass with each
other
this power includes himself and other
people he uses this ability to get
Esther OSA into a chokehold when he
attacks him in derry airy as derriere
points out he also isn't hurt by a
cirrhosis he'll blaze attack because he
is one of the greatest wielders of
hellfire even in the demon world thus
Monts Pete was able to immobilize Esther
Ossa
something that I don't believe derriere
II could have done however derriere he
lets down her guard gets too close to
esta rosa who takes advantage and almost
kills her before mon speed uses his
ability to switch places with her
sacrificing his own life for the person
he loves so sensible on speed could get
the advantage against Testarossa until
derriere he messed it up and since even
after that he could distract him long
enough for derriere ii to reach
elizabeth i have to put mon speed over
derriere ii on this list next up we have
zelgius the commandant of piety
according to the official guide while he
was given a base power level of
61,000 already putting him above
everyone else mentioned so far however
this power level does not do him justice
at all he is able to fight against much
stronger opponents his father the demon
king lent him some of his power which
makes magic attacks useless against him
when you combine this ability with his
original power ominous nebulae you get
one of the most Opie combinations in the
series
ominous nebula sucks enemies into him
and they can't launch a physical attack
since when they get close enough
his quickly swirling dark energy cuts
them apart this move works so quickly
that even Ludo shell with His grace
flash is not fast enough to stop it
remember that Ludo Shah at this point
has a combat class of 200 and 1000 and
he cannot do anything to zelgius zelgius
doesn't even need to undergo and endure
a transformation to defeat him however
unluckily for zelgius it happens to be
high noon when he uses that attack and
the one puts a stop to it nevertheless
zelgius is easily stronger than any of
the previously mentioned members on this
list next we have ester OSA or rather
mile s rosa was always strong but ever
since he regained his memories of being
mile and his sunshine ability he is
stronger than ever
mile with sunshine is even stronger than
s Kannur in the one mode he simply has
to get close to zelgius when he is using
ominous nebula in zelgius a sword melts
the same sword that was used to stop the
once karate chop the fact that miele can
overpower zelgius as he is and he
doesn't even need to enter the one mode
to do it shows how strong he truly is
and how much stronger he can potentially
become if afternoon mile is stronger
than s Kannur in the one mode then you
can bet that mile in the one mode is
insanely powerful I really hope we get
to see it at one point lastly for fun
I'll also mentioned Mele OTUs who was at
one point the leader of the Ten
Commandment I believe that if we
included him he should rest at the top
of the list
even before he awakens his original Opie
power in purgatory
Mele ODIs in Chapter 246 was able to
effortlessly overpower ester OSA zelgius
with the demon Kings power and cusack at
the same time now he's unlocked his
original power that is strong enough to
destroy the demon King's entire arm a
feat that no one else was able to get
close to accomplishing
far most likely the original power is
also what allowed him to destroy an
entire kingdom on par with Leonys and
strength in a moment of Wrath and what
allowed him to leave a lasting scar on
bonds immortal body meliodas suggests
that the power once awakened is so
strong that he won't be able to stay in
the human world we haven't heard of
anyone else including mile with sunshine
being too strong to be able to stay in
the human world
so this does suggest that malleolus will
be on another level plus it is possible
that after bond and malleolus defeat the
demon king Mele Otis will keep the power
of the ten commandments for himself
which would further increase is already
insane power mile with sunshine was no
match for the demon king in melee Otis's
body but we don't know how mile in the
one mode would fare against them
nevertheless because of what we've seen
from malleolus so far and because he
could quite possibly inherit the power
of the ten commandments soon I have to
give him the number one spot and that is
it for today's video guys thanks for
watching make sure to smash that like
button if you enjoyed the video if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and ring
that notification bell for more seven
deadly sins videos leave your
suggestions for future videos in the
comments that isn't enough seven deadly
sins for you check out our Instagram for
daily seven deadly sins content a big
thing who goes out to our patrons
especially to our pro tier patrons a
seventeen ffvp keelon and the one and
only Gilgamesh if you like what we do
consider supporting more videos like
this for as little as a dollar a month
think about it that's even less than a
Starbucks coffee and you'd even get your
name feature in future videos among
these awesome people right here
you can also buy anime inspired shirts
like meliodas feel the wrath and esken
or praise the sun at Anime uproar calm
link in the description fans of the
channel even get 25% off just use the
code up for 25 at checkout thank you for
your support and until next time see us
space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]